welcome i'm liu jimura a senior
principal his social at microsoft
today i want to tell you about the
augmented mathematical intelligence
project ami for short our goal is to
assist humans in mathematical problem
solving
our session today is divided in three
parts i'm going to start telling you
about the link to improver form of
mathematics in the ami project
then professor kevin buzzas will tell
you how lean is in the frontiers being
used in the frontiers of mathematics
professor buzzard is a member of the
link community
and one of the developers of math lib
the lean mathematical library
in the last part dr daniel celson is
going to tell you about ada the air
system for mathematics being built at
microsoft
you should view the link to improver as
a development environment for
mathematics here we have visual studio
code being used to edit a simple link
file
lin has definitions you are defining two
functions in this example the vowel and
times function line has definitions but
it also has theorems
here the theorem evolved times is
proving a simple property about the
times function defined as above
like modern programming languages
you can you will have intellisensingly
you can hover over any objects in your
file and you give you additional
information about these objects we also
have auto completion and features such
as jump to definition this is really
useful as it is useful in for software
development is also used
very useful for mathematics when you're
proving a complex term sometimes you you
are using another theme that has been
proven before and being able to jump to
the definition of this theorem is
extremely useful
on the right panel we have the lean info
view right it gives you additional
information about any points in your
file in this example you can click
anywhere in the proof and then you show
you the exact stage of the proof at that
point this is very useful when you are
navigating a complex proof
develops using lean for more information
about the lean projects you can click
the link on the bottom of these
slides are very grateful for the link
community the lean project has the
contributions of countless volunteers
here we have an animation built by andre
bauer
he uses information
storage on github in the math lab
repository here we see hundreds of
mathematicians working together
something we have never seen before
we say this is a math hive the lee
mathematical library is paper is
authored by the math lib community there
will be so many authors in this paper
that we decide to use just the math lib
community
for more information about the link
community you can follow the link on the
bottom of these slides
in the link community websites you are
going to find manuals documentation
educational material games built on top
of link
and you can browse the math lib library
without even installing lean in this
example here we have documentation for
the category of schemes an object that
is part of the algebraic geometry module
methyleb is not just important for math
but also for software verification
suppose that you're a software developer
building the next generation crypto
library
number theory is essential if you want
to prove purpose about your
new algorithm you can use math lab
because it has many many theories about
number theorem that are there that can
be reused by you
the math lib project is started in 2017
and is growing rapidly
today we have more than 27 000
definitions
60 000 theorems and almost 200
contributors
more than 600 000 lines of code have
been written in meth lib
mflib is also the foundation for more
complex projects like the link effectoid
spaces
developed by kevin buzzers johann
cummelin and patrick massour
here this group explained what peter
shows definition of perfectoid space is
to lean this is a very complex
definition this is fields level
fields metal level mathematics right
this object is extremely complex
and it's really hard to explain in using
informal language
but here you have a digital version a
formal version of these objects you can
navigate through these objects using vs
codes right visual studio codes for
example if you don't know what a tate's
ring is you can just click on this
object and ask visual studio code to
jump to its
definition by having these objects
formalizing lean we also can use this
data to create visualizations
automatically the graph on the right
hand side was generates automatically by
a program written in linked by patrick
masso here we see all the dependencies
of this project
if you go to the math overflow websites
this popular website uses by
mathematicians for asking questions
you're going to find a question about
uh perfectoid spaces and one of the most
popular answers
is is a answer that is just a link to
the lean development right to this
project that was being done using the
link to improver
recurrence question is should i trust
lin
lien's a big piece of code and like any
big piece of software it contains bugs
and now you may wonder
are the teams providing lean really
correct
well lean has a small trusted proof
checker lee may be big but this proof
checker
the link kernel is a small piece of code
right much much smaller than ling itself
well you may say well it's small but it
may still have bugs right
well
you can export your proofs you can
export your proofs and check them with
external checkers
right
these checkers have been implemented in
different programming languages such as
haskell scala rust to cytofield
they were not implemented by us the lean
developers but by the community
right and still you may not stress these
checkers too
you may decide to implement your own
check this is feasible any one of these
checkers is not a big piece of code it's
between 1 000 and two thousand lines of
code you can implement your own if you
want
we're enabling decentralized
collaboration with the link projects we
have two main ingredients here we have
meta programming the ability to extend
lean using itself
you can prove terms using lean but as we
said before you can also use link to
define functions some of the functions
are mathematical functions but some of
them can be extensions to lean itself
you can implement proof automation that
are programs that automated repetitive
steps when you're proving a theorem you
can build visualization tools like the
one that generates the graph on the
bottom of these slides
and custom notation right
formal proofs allow us
to reuse proofs from each other without
trusting each other you can use my
proofs without trusting me i'm a human i
can make mistakes but any proof built by
someone else can be checked by the proof
chrono the link kernel this small piece
of code
more importantly you can also use my
proof automation
no matter how complicated this piece of
code is that's generating proofs
automatically for you without trusting
my abilities
we say you can hack without fear this is
essential for the lean aba assistant
right ada is a complex piece of software
you don't need to trust it it will
produce a
formal proof that can be checked by the
link kernel
uh the future is now the ling
projects have impacts today here you
have two articles the first one on the
wired magazine describes the efforts of
building math lib it interviews many
mathematicians that are part of the link
community and as i said mfleb is the
foundation for more ambitious projects
like the liquid tensor experiments that
has been recently reported by nature
there
the lean community assisted peter chosey
a fields medalist to ensure his new
result is correct the theory he cares
about was so complex that not even him
could navigate this complex theorem we
are going to learn more about this
project
uh in the next part when kevin brothers
will do a deep dive
these are just two examples on the lean
website you're going to find many other
articles in
popular science magazines podcasts
and videos right that are accessible
even if you don't know
formal mathematics team proving or math
itself
we believe the ami project we will
accelerate the revolution g's project
has two main pillars on one side we have
the mathematical digitalization efforts
where we are creating progressive tower
of abstractions libraries and two
systems all mathematics
this part will fit the second one the
machine problem solving part where we're
developing ai that we will train
digitized math to solve problems
automatically this ai will assist humans
digitizing more math creating a positive
feedback loop
today you can track progress on
undergraduate level mathematics
digitalization online following the link
on the top of these slides a lot has
been done but you have a long way to go
the ami projects will accelerate
progress here
we also believe you are ready for bigger
challenges like digitalizing fermat's
last theorem
thermos last theorem is easy to state
but the proof is massive it's fair to
say that no human today knows every
single detail of this proof
by having it in digital form formalized
in ling you will be able to zoom in to
any detail of this proof the commit the
link community believe
believes you are ready to attack this
kind of problem and the ami project will
support these efforts another great
challenge is the formalization of the
stacks library this library contains
more than 7 000 pages of algebraic
geometry
this is a valuable source of information
but such engines do not work well in
this domain
today's search engines cannot answer
basic questions such as has this term
been privileged before
we believe right the email make a big
difference here
as professor bazaar says we're just
alizing math and we'll make it better
the machine problem solving pillar
rights is where
ada is the main ingredient here the in
the base of this on the base of this
pillar we have the limp proof checker
this small piece of code that can check
any proof built using lean users are
going to use visual studio codes or any
other editor that support the
the language server protocol disasters
are sending commands to link that will
assemble the proofs for us
links using proof automation symbolic
reasoning as an example a user can ask
link to simplify a formula reduce its
complexity a user can ask lin to solve a
system of equations automatically for
them right all these tasks algorithmic
we have procedures and they exist today
terms in math are built on top of each
other we need a strong foundation and
this is what is being provided by math
lib and finally we have ada our air
system that will be running on the
clouds right ada is a complex piece of
software but you don't need to trust ada
aid is producing formal proofs formal
objects that can be checked by the lean
proof checker it will assist
mathematicians to achieve more
this is the end of the first part of our
session thank you very much for your
attention in the next part
professor buzzards will tell you more
about lean
meth lib and the liquid tensor
experiments
thank you
thank you very much leo
my name is kevin buzzard and i'm a
professor of pure mathematics at
imperial college in london
uh so in the next 15 minutes the plan is
i'm going to say something about what
modern mathematics is and what
mathematicians do
i'm going to say something about the
relationship between mathematicians and
computers and i'm going to end by
describing an ongoing project in a
rapidly developing new area somewhere
between
somewhere on the boundary between
mathematics and computer science work
which spans several areas like this is
often very interesting because uh it can
give rise to a synergy and insights when
experts in different areas start
discussing uh
the same material
so there's the plan and we're going to
start by talking about what
mathematicians do
so for very young children most people
meet mathematics as a young child
mathematics they see is often about
calculating numerical values first first
we learned to count then we learned
addition subtraction and multiplication
and then we learned algorithms such as
column addition and then we're faced
with questions like you know what's 158
plus 91 and the idea is we have a method
we have an algorithm
column addition you write these numbers
down with the units in the same column
and the tens in the same column and
you add things up line by line and we
learn the algorithm and then we can add
up very large numbers like this and
we're also taught geometry at a young
age and geometry gives us a new you know
a new source of questions involving
calculations
but actually geometry uh can also be the
cause of headaches
among students because
there are high school geometry questions
where
there isn't a method where you can't
just apply the method you actually have
to think about the facts that you know
and put them together in the right order
an innovative order this is like the art
of mathematics for example you might be
taught theorems about angles in
triangles and angles in parallel lines
and then you're faced with some diagram
with some triangles and some parallel
lines and you're asked to compute some
angle
and uh the direct computation won't work
we don't know what the angle is but you
can start using facts circle theorems or
triangle theorems and to figure out new
information from information you have
and you have to use your intuition more
so some students find these uh questions
more difficult than the calculation
questions because there's no method
a university level uh even more emphasis
is placed on reasoning so i i often see
students coming into my university who
are very strong at calculations but you
know they want to know what the method
is what's the method they ask and
unfortunately sometimes there is no
method you know sometimes you just have
to use the tools you have uh in
innovative ways and really you know the
key ideas are you need to learn how to
use the tools
which we're teaching you at university
and research mathematics is just the
same thing it's a mixture of calculating
and reasoning
so you know this is a broad
generalization but uh pure
mathematicians are people whose work is
mostly about reasoning you know they
define new structures and they prove
theorems about these structures using
only the rules of mathematics
and they you know we develop theoretical
tools in in the pure math side of things
and applied mathematicians use these
tools to solve real world problems for
example they might be uh you're
interested in things like weather
prediction or internet security in fact
uh some of the early examples of
encryption techniques which were used
for things like online credit card
transactions on the internet these were
you know these were invented using
tools which were developed by number
theorists many years earlier so pure
mathematicians develop the tools and
applied mathematicians use them and
calculations may well be a key part of
the work of an applied mathematician
so where do computers fit into all this
well of course uh way before computers
mathematicians were using machines to do
calculations for them
for example the abacus or the slide rule
but when computers came along
mathematicians almost instantly
started using them
to do to do their calculations and
nowadays of course you know the
computers are ubiquitous in mathematics
departments and of course you know many
other places as well
uh but the question is what about the
pure mathematicians who want to do
reasoning can we use computers to reason
or or can we can we use computers to
help humans
with their reasoning
can can computers help pure
mathematicians and you might be quite
surprised to know that actually uh
computers computers are used far less
often by pure mathematicians than
applied mathematicians
to give an example in the 1990s richard
taylor and andrew wiles proved fermat's
last theorem this was an old question
that had been open for hundreds of years
it was a statement about numbers
but the proof did not involve computers
at all the proof just involved
using complex structures and proving
theorems about these structures you know
using
using pen and paper
so why are computers not being used in
this domain
let me explain the fundamental problem
with it
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
the birch and swinolus and dye
conjecture this is a conjecture
this is a conjecture about cubic
equations in two variables
here's an example of y squared is x
cubed plus 37. so what does the birch
and switzerland conjecture say about
this equation
well they start off by attaching two
numbers to this equation
uh one of the numbers uh you create
using algebra which is the study of the
discrete and the the other number you
create using analysis
which is the study of the continuous so
there are two numbers that one can
attach to such an equation and the
techniques we use are very very
different
uh to calculate those two numbers
and uh the observation of merchants
winners and dire their conjecture is
that those two numbers which are
attached to the equation one using
algebra and one using analysis uh the
conjecture is that those two numbers are
always equal
so this is an unsolved problem and it's
in fact an incredibly famous problem
it's a clay millennium problem uh the
clay foundation uh published a list of
seven problems uh in the year 2000 that
they thought mathematicians should be
working on
in the 21st century and they offered a
million dollar prize for each of these
uh for each of these conjectures and
this was this was one of these
conjectures
uh so if you can solve the virtual
swindlers and die conjecture you get a
million dollars so why aren't we solving
it using computers
uh let me let me try and explain why
that is the
ironically uh the uh the conjecture was
discovered uh by computer
experimentation
uh with very early computers but here's
the reason that you can't prove the
birch finish and die conjecture using a
computer in the naive way the virtual
swindlers and die conjecture is a
statement about all cubic equations in
two variables
and so it's a statement about infinitely
many equations you see numbers are
infinite this is one of the first things
we learn about them we learn to count
and then we realize that for every
number there's a number after it
so the burst insulin dietary statement
about infinitely many equations and thus
it cannot be solved by a finite
calculation you can check it for a
million of these cubic equations or even
a billion or a trillion but there's
infinitely many so in some sense you've
got nowhere
so
what is mathematics a mathematical
problem it's just a logic puzzle really
just like a sudoku puzzle or a chess
puzzle and of course we can teach
computers the rules of sudoku or of
chess and similarly we can teach
computers the rules of mathematics but
uh one of the consequences of teaching
computers the rules of sudoku is that
computers can solve sudoku problems in a
fraction of a second and one of the
consequences of having taught computers
the rules of chess is that computers can
now beat chess gram masters at chess
computers have got very very good at
these things so we can teach computers
the rules of mathematics and the lean
theorem prover you know written by
microsoft research is exactly that it's
a computer proof system which knows
these rules
so this is the very beginning of the
adventure as far as mathematicians are
concerned but unfortunately because
mathematics is infinite there's
infinitely many numbers unlike chess or
sudoku
mathematics is a game being played on an
infinite board so the techniques we have
to solve sudoku problems uh or to beat
grand masters of chess they might not
scale to mathematics because we have to
leap from the finite to the infinite and
this is what makes the question so much
more difficult
so can computers help humans
do their mathematical research involving
reasoning i guess as a first step
we have to consider the much simpler
question which is can computers even
understand the questions
uh which mathematical researchers are
considering in 2021
and this is one of the goals of lean's
mathematics library math lib matam is a
gigantic database of definitions and
theorems which pure mathematicians use
and it's growing all the time it's about
four years old it's well over half a
million lines of code now it's
approaching two-thirds of a million
lines of code and it contains
all essentially all of undergraduate
pure mathematics well you know most of
it by now a lot of msc level mathematics
and we're encroaching into research
level
into research level mathematics this is
this is one of the absolute
prerequisites for getting for getting
pure mathematicians
that are doing reasoning to use
computers the first thing we have to do
is to make sure they understand the
question and this is you know we have a
very viable uh we have a very viable
approach for this more and more of the
research level questions which
mathematicians are working on can be
understood by lean equipped with its
maths library math lib
so right now what can we do with this
library right now this gigantic library
we can use it with undergraduate
teaching i use it to teach
undergraduates in a new way
uh matip opens up the possibilities for
search if you if you want to know if a
theorem is improved you can search the
database to see if it's in the library
semantic search is a is a big deal for
mathematicians and as you know as the
systems get better we're going to be
seeing more and more mathematicians
using these for search
matlab can also be used as a you know
it's a big it's a big amount of data so
ai people can use it to train you know
they can train their machine learning
algorithms on this big chunk of data but
also it can be used by other projects
that want to engage with a small amount
of harder mathematics
modern research level mathematics you
can use math lib as a dependency in that
way
so let me end by talking about the
liquid tensor experiment uh here's the
background to this the fields medal is
like the nobel prize of mathematics and
the 2018 phil's medalist peter schulzer
and his collaborator dustin clausen they
proved a theorem in 2020 which enables
us to use algebraic techniques in
certain areas of geometry where this was
not previously possible
so the hope is these techniques are
already yielding new proofs of old
results and the hope is that these
techniques will go on
to give us a new way of attacking
questions in this area and proving new
theorems in this area of geometry
where this where these uh where these
theorems apply
so in late 2020 uh peter schulzer raised
the following challenge he said uh can
these computer proof systems check a key
result in his work so it's it's
interesting to ask why did he ask this
question and the reason he asked this
question was schulzer looked at how the
mathematical community were assimilating
his results and kind of and using them
and beginning to understand them and he
became concerned that they were not
checking the the intricate details of
the arguments for example he asked me
whether our study group in london had uh
had checked these careful details and
we'd looked at lots of the things that
they were doing but we hadn't gone
through everything with a fine-tooth
cone and shelter said this is new
material and i believe it's very
important this needs to be checked and
i'm not convinced that the human system
is scaling
right is the idea is that humans check
other humans work but when it comes to
technical things shultz was asking
people and people were saying well you
know we just kind of assumed these
things and didn't didn't check all the
details carefully
so he began to wonder whether a
computer-proof system you know whether
they're powerful enough in 2021 uh to
actually embark on trying to check some
of his results
so by early 2021 uh the key technical
intermediate lemma which he felt that no
human had checked properly it had been
isolated and we'd stated it
in the lean theorem prover using this
gigantic math slide we had a project
that sat on top of that maths library
and we'd stated the question so now
the challenge becomes a computer game
can we can we prove
can we prove this theorem and a group of
mathematicians from all over the world
started working on this they were
collaborating online using the internet
this is somehow you know we were doing
mathematics in a new way and a few
months later we managed to prove
this lemma that shelter was worried
about
and this is his response
he said you know as part of a blog post
i'm excited to announce
that the experimenters verified the
entire part of the argument that i was
unsure about i find it absolutely insane
that interactive proof of systems are
now at that level where within a very
reasonable time span they can formally
verify
original research
so this was
this was the lean theorem prover in its
maths library being used to actually
help a modern mathematician you know
with a with an interesting problem that
they'd come up with they weren't
convinced that the community were
reading
their work
so just to summarize then lean's maths
library massively it can turn
mathematics into a computer game there
are other systems which can also do this
but the difference between matlab is
it's engaging with research level
mathematics and turning that into a
computer game
so it's also enabling collaboration at
scale there are many people that can
work on on one project together using
the kind of collaboration tools we have
nowadays
uh and we're also you know modeling
difficult modern abstract objects on a
computer we don't really know where this
is going but this is like digitizing
mathematics this is something that
hadn't been done before digitizing
modern mathematics so it's it's taking
us into unknown territory
thank you very much
hi everybody my name is daniel selsum
and i'll be discussing a new effort
we're launching to build an ai assistant
for mathematics and our project is
called ada named after this wonderful
art installation in the lobby of the
microsoft research building in redmond
now here is the dream the dream is that
a lean user
defines a formal statement of some
hypothesis of interest in this case the
the famous riemann hypothesis and just
ask the system to prove it and then ada
the future version of ada will start
searching and maybe a few seconds or
weeks or decades later ada claims that
it finds a proof now it doesn't matter
how inscrutable ada is it might just be
a large neural network it might be
something even wilder it might have
evolved in some kind of physics
evolutionary simulation it doesn't
matter and it also doesn't matter how
sophisticated or incomprehensible the
proof it finds is
it might be a billion lines of alien
mathematics that's beyond the capacity
of any human brain to understand this
also doesn't matter because as long as
it produces a formal proof the lean
kernel can verify it for us at which
point we have essentially a hundred
percent confidence that the riemann
hypothesis has been proved and the world
rejoices now the dream extends beyond
just mathematical proof so in this
example
a user might define precisely what it
means to be a gradient optimizer in some
context they might define some precise
mathematical property of such an
optimizer for example that it has some
amazing regret bound and asks the system
to discover a gradient optimizer that
satisfies this property and as before
ada may uh find may start searching and
find a candidate gradient optimizer and
it can find a proof that it satisfies
this amazing regret bound and then as
before it doesn't matter how complicated
ada is it doesn't matter how complicated
the optimizer is or the proof
lean can successfully verify the proof
for us and in this case maybe the user
profits because their ml system trains
more effectively and the dream extends
even further beyond proof beyond
mathematical logic itself to include
empirical metrics so in this example a
user is asking the system to discover
some assembly language program that has
the same mathematical semantics as some
baseline python script and that also
best effort empirically minimizes a
performance on some benchmark
and ada may find a candidate program
lean can confirm that this program gives
you a million x speed up on this
performance benchmark and then ada can
find a proof that it's correct at which
point even if the assembly language
program and the proof of correctness are
inscrutable uh it doesn't matter we all
have uh very very high essentially 100
confidence that this program does what
we want and in this case uh oh sorry
after lean successfully verifies the
proof we have this confidence and then
in this case maybe the organization says
let's super optimize all of our systems
or let's rethink how we develop all
software
now this dream may seem ridiculous it
may seem as out of reach as zipping
through wormholes but i want to note
that it is merely an algorithmic problem
it is not a philosophical problem we as
a community know how to write formal
statements in mathematics in computer
science and statistics and machine
learning in software engineering across
the mathematical sciences we can write
formal encodings of even very very
sophisticated theorems and as leo
stressed
lean can already verify arbitrarily
sophisticated proofs so there's very
little trusted code there are actually
multiple independent proof checkers
written in different languages usually
only between one and two thousand lines
of code each there's a well understood
meta theory it's essentially a hundred
percent trustworthy and to stress one
more time
already today's lien can check
arbitrarily sophisticated proofs even
ones that might be produced by super
intelligent systems of the future
and finally lean provides a perfect
simulator for mathematics so ai's can
experiment on their own there's no need
to wait for
humans to to respond to provide
subjective feedback there's no need to
run physics i.e to see if the robot hand
actually picks up the jar in reality
there's no gap between
sim and real in our scenario if a system
learns to prove sophisticated theorems
in simulation it is learned to prove
sophisticated theorems period and we're
really excited to be launching a
long-term campaign to realize this
ambitious dream now here's our very very
very high level strategy
we want to use symbolic methods to
formulate math as a kind of game
that rl agents uh maybe not today's but
of the not too distant future can win
and our mantra is that symbolic methods
define the game and statistical methods
play the game
now the game of math is like go in many
ways i do think this is a useful analogy
but at the same time it's almost
incompre almost incomparably more
sophisticated and challenging than go so
first in the game of math the state is
massive and growing all the time so in
go the state is just a 19 by 19 array of
triples with a little bit of extra
history data but in math it's this
massive environment object that includes
all mathematics that has been formalized
so far all definitions lemmas theorems
proofs all meta programs that have been
used to help produce those proofs and
all of the the formulae and the goals
and the proof steps only make sense in
the context of this ever growing
environments
and also in math actions can be long and
complex so in go an action is just a row
column pair
but in math an action is an arbitrarily
large formula or proof step and new
usually higher order action primitives
are constantly being added to the state
by humans and eventually by other ais
and to make things even worse proofs may
require not just one but arbitrarily
long sequences of such complex actions
with little or no intermediate feedback
or reward before luckily stumbling on a
proof of some deep result
and lastly there's no clear way to
bootstrap so in go deepmind was able to
train a superhuman go player from first
principles by having the system play
against itself over and over again and
this is a beautiful and inspiring
approach but there's no obvious analog
in mathematics so math is really only a
well-defined game for specific
conjectures that are fixed
you can sort of think of math as a
two-player game where one player
conjectures and the other proves but
this is somewhat arbitrary formulation
and it's a very asymmetric game anyway
and it doesn't have the right dynamics
to bootstrap i'd say it's a it's an open
philosophical question if there are
proxy metrics for mathematics that can
turn human style theory building into a
game at all
and the game of math is also
uh quite a bit like the sequence to
sequence problem that current large
language models have been excelling at
but there's also
another big important difference which
is that the outputs in the game of math
are held to a much much higher semantic
bar
than is currently achievable by the
state of the art in other words the
outputs have to really really make
rigorous semantic sense and this is
right now very far beyond the state of
the art
now um
we this dream is obviously very broad
and open-ended so we wanted to come up
with a grand challenge that was in the
spirit of this dream
but was still very very concrete and so
we've proposed the imo grand challenge
which is to build an ai that can win a
gold medal in the international
mathematical olympiad or imo which is
perhaps the most prestigious mental
competition in the world and we think
it's a great proxy for the broader dream
there's an ongoing supply of new devious
problems that are thought to require
tremendous ingenuity even for humans or
machines that have studied all previous
problems there's a well-defined notion
of success which is winning a gold medal
and there's broad consensus that there's
no plausible way to brute force these
problems they're they're really very
sophisticated problems
but the downside of this challenge is
that it's a very extremely unforgiving
metric so it's hard to even get a single
point on this challenge so our plan is
to build up gradually from easier
problems and easier competitions
now as leo stressed uh the lean
community has been the major driving
force of lean and we want to build
similar community around the the ai
research questions so please please come
talk to us and help us better articulate
and contextualize the key scientific
challenges help us produce the right
intermediate benchmarks and metrics to
measure and spur progress in in many
different of the ai subfields help us
develop and expose the right apis to
support experimentation and also help us
develop the mechanisms that will
incentivize public goods for example
formalizing historical problems for use
as both training data and evaluation
data and i'm i want to close by saying
that i'm really excited to discuss and
collaborate with many of you moving
forward thank you so much
you